this is the story of mankind our beliefs
our struggles our traditions and our
inspirations this is the story of us
once again
my journeys take me around the world
meeting inspiring individuals from all
walks of life and as always I've got a
lot of questions do you think that
justice and revenge or different about
who we are and what joins us all
together over 100 walls like this we'll
put up a cross northern island who are
you
the solution for me it's education on
having both communities working together
from the very outset of life can we turn
hate and to understand it how can you
hate me you don't even know me after 48
years as a little bit that answer what
makes someone want to repel are you not
afraid for your safety this is what we
have to do president Morales went from a
resistance leader to president of this
country they think love has to be
learned when people peace among helping
another person I think it's affection
and love truly conquer all if you
thought you were going to lose everyone
that you love what would you do and what
keeps the fire of freedom burning in our
darkest hour Albert Woodfox four decades
of solitary confinement
ree-ally I am Ward's up
I found that although we come from
different places
with different backgrounds
have vastly different ideas we are all
bound together by our humanity
[Music]
this is the story of us
you
[Music]
you
[Music]